[Music]
we'll be doing a live coding session
using functional programming for
java programmers and scholar programmers
future scholar programmers the
presentation is for beginners so we'll
start with
how
and why of the pure function so we need
a pure function
that will
return one value
and
calculate the return
value based only on the arguments and
doesn't mutate any existing function
only those three things mean that we
deal with pure function and to test it
out we'll see some first pure functions
like five of them
and we'll be able to find out whether
they are pure or not this is very
important thing to understand
when you see a code or you basically
write it write a code you want to in
functional programming you want to write
pure functions and we'll see
why in a bit so increment is a pure
function it doesn't mutate it uses only
arguments and returns only one value
always random part this is a tricky one
because it's not pure it's returns one
value it uses uh more than the argument
so it also uses a math random so it's
outside of the
parameter list that means that it's not
a pure function and we will not be able
to
uh to understand and comprehend
what kind of value do we get when we
call it with the same argument
add
it is a pure function so this this
thermometer is very useful for to
for beginners to find out
whether the
the function
is pure or not so add
is a pure function but what about like a
java very very javas
java specific class like from from
object oriented
paradigm so we have a shopping cart with
lists of items and then we have this add
item function is it pure or not well it
isn't it mutates
uh it mutates existing values in this
case it mutates items
um field and this is of course this
object oriented programming so it's
probably it's probably okay but we don't
really want to use that in functional
programming so this is not a pure
function we won't be writing functions
like that this is impure one and a final
one for the test is a
get first character
car add
so it's a simple function but it's not a
pure one uh to surprise of many
because it doesn't really return one
value sometimes it doesn't return any
value at all especially when we call it
with this with empty
empty string right because it will throw
an exception will not return a value so
this is also not a pure
function for some but let's let's uh use
this kind of definition we are starting
the the live coding session right now so
functional programming is programming
using pure functions
that manipulate immutable values so
that's that's the
two things that may make up functional
programming pure functions and immutable
values we'll do a
exercise just like in the book just like
in a grocking functional programming
book this is like excerpt from from the
beginning of real really beginning of of
the book uh the book is for for
beginners with we take gradual steps and
uh the gradual steps mean that we
use java first and only then we switch
to a more functional programming
language and this live coding session
will be just like that we'll start with
java we'll see some problems
and then we will use functional
programming to solve those problems
so let's let's have a a simple
uh task
so we have a trip to plan
let's say we have a like we want to go
to paris in berlin and krakow
and this is plan a but then one of our
friends
um suggested that we may
try a little bit different trip
itinerary and we may visit vienna before
krakow so we need a function that will
and that will replan
that trip in this case we'll call it
replan and we want to use pure function
so it will be like replant plan a
and
let's put vienna before krakow so that's
what the parameter lists a list mean so
we'll we need to create in java we need
to create a function let's replan
we take plan insert new city before
city
and uh that's the
function
that's what the function needs to
needs to do let's switch to
the code we need to create an
implementation for a function uh replan
uh that will
put the new city before the city in the
plan that we we give so it it should be
it should be pretty pretty uh
straightforward right so
so first
uh let's uh we're in java
so let's create a
let's get an index of the before of
before city like so index off in java so
now we have an index
and since we have an index then we can
just add
at this index
a new city
city
right
and
uh
we can return it so this is a
problematic implementation and
um
we see that
uh we we return that plan why why is it
problematic it's like a normal java
function we can use so let's let's try
to run it we have a main function main
function here so we added
this plan a paris berlin krakow and then
we want to replan it and add vienna
before krakow right so that's that's the
functionality we want to do
and
let's let's run it so let's see what
happens when when we run it we see that
we have plan a which is
powered in krakow then we re-plan it
and
we print it out
like in the in this line
so we get vienna before krakow that's
okay that's pretty fine
and
then we print the plan a again
and we see that it's different than the
one here
and it may be surprising and it is
surprising in many many applications
especially in production in the night
when you get a call
so what we need to do
is we need to
is we need to
somehow
deal with this this kind of problem on
our own so we first need to understand
what the problem is and the problem is
on the left side you can see the memory
right what we want what we kind of think
happens we get a plan a this is a this
is a
value with a list
and then it's passed to the function
replan as parameter plan
and we get as plan
paris berlin krakow and then
we
what we do
is uh
we just uh create an uh a new
uh new
city inside this this this plan so we
think that we are like modifying the
plan inside the function and then just
returning it
but what happens really is that uh the
plan a and plan are the same
the same objects right
so uh we don't really
we don't really know what happens
outside of of a replant function
and unfortunately when someone calls
replant function they also don't don't
know what happens with this and
since those are all mutable lists
uh when we call plan add we add it to
the object and it's visible
everywhere so that's the problem so it's
like a simple representation of this
problem but it is uh it's surface
surfaces a lot in a lot of applications
that do
this kind of uh
imperative object oriented approach so
we
um in terms of functional programming
what we really have is uh at the heart
what we really have at our hearts very
very deep inside is to avoid mutability
at all costs so we don't really want to
uh to ask those kind of questions we
don't want to have those problems we
don't want to
ask
if it's a view or can we modify it at
that or
do the
lists that we return
modify or are mutable or not
uh
so uh is someone really
trying to modify some something uh
inside a function that we call things
like that so we don't really want those
problems we want to solve business
problems
so either we plan a pure function no it
isn't although
we
may
may have assumed that it is a pure
function because when you look at the
signature you can see that replan
takes a list of strings and and returns
lists of strings so this is like a very
very clear sign that uh
it returns a new value so if if it would
be
if it's a void and we would probably
understand that it needs to mutate
something it's not pure but here the
signature tells us a different story
uh than the implementation
so in java world we have lots of those
kind of
functions like the apis are really uh
not
consistent with uh with uh themselves uh
so we have a functions that return void
when we remove something we we have
functions that return boolean when they
add something and we have a sub list
function that returns a list of string
but
it's really inside a view and this view
is not really a view
and because the
if you modify something in the view it
also
appears in the original list so lots of
very very chaotic api design here
and
when we
when we have those kind of apis we we
really want to switch to something
that's more
uh maintainable that's mo that's more
understandable that doesn't have any
surprises
and
it turns out that we have something like
that in different languages even in java
and this this kind of approaches is
called
immutability right so what we
do we fight mutability by not mutating
anything so we don't really mutate we
just copy we just copy copy copy and
and that's why we really don't don't
mutate any existing values and this is
built in in many functional languages
but let's
first do that
let's first do that in
in java
so what we can do is we can get this
replan replant function
and
we can
uh create a pure version of this replant
function and this pure version needs
something more because what it needs
it needs a
new list here
list of string
which will be
replant
and this is a new array list
of so we are creating a here we are
creating a copy
uh a copy of this
of this list and then we can just
add
add to this new copy the thing that we
wanted to add and return it and this way
we we can really uh do lots of cool
things
because now when when i run this program
and it's
it's the same program but it uses this
new new function you can see that the
pure version
uh behaves like we probably want it to
behave that means that plan a is plan a
forever so plan a doesn't really change
plan a
can be
displayed on ui can be saved to database
so that's that's at the the heart of
function programming the heart of
immutability so we have always the old
history of all the objects that we want
uh we we have and they cannot really
change so plan a
plan b replan created a new version we
saved as plan b and so plan a stayed the
same
and
that's that's
a story
that we can use in java but there are
some some problems the the main problem
is that the shared mutable state doesn't
disappear it's not like we just created
a copy and and we got rid of the problem
the main problem remains the same so
shared mutable state shared meaning that
uh
it's shared between many different uh
entities in the in our program it's
mutable it's mutable so the value won't
stay the same
we don't have this kind of guarantee and
state means that this is a value stores
in one place and axis in some other
uh so something that that's like
kept
as a value
so our replant function manages the
the state the mutable shed mutable state
when we look at the just just the plan
parameter the first parameter of this
function we see that this is a state
because it can be accessed it's stored
somewhere it's passed here so we don't
really create it it's mutable because
arraylist or list in general in java is
visible
and it's shared
we know it's shared because we just got
a reference to it and uh from the like
from the client so so we shared it be
between the main function and and here
so it shared mutable state and we
managed it pretty pretty nicely because
we created a copy but we don't have this
kind of guarantee right so
this is a building block of imperative
programming but it also adds a lot of
cognitive load on programmers because
they need to understand where this kind
of state can be mutated
where is it past who has access who
hasn't end things like uh who can call
it who can change it
so more design general questions that
they may ask
you